sono
da torino e per la diamo
la mia vita mi sono occupato punto di
filosofia
prima da studente poi da ricercatore
all'università di torino e da circa due
anni e mezzo
l'ho abbandonata
almeno accademicamente e mi sono
impegnato in un progetto appunto di
start up con mio fratello e quindi direi
che capirete il mio stupore quando non
più di una settimana fa
la filosofia mi si è ripresentata in
questa forma
questa una notifica di twitter che ho
ricevuto e
canta iniziato a seguirmi e una cosa che
non mi sarei mai aspettato devo chiedere
se vale per i concorsi universitari non
ne sono sicuro però insomma fa effetto
tant'è che poi ho condiviso
immediatamente questa immagine con gli
amici i quali ovviamente hanno
commentato in maniera del tutto
prevedibile guarda che adesso inizierà a
criticare per tempo fa il troll nei
commenti
ho pensato che questa fosse una metafora
piuttosto vivida del mio momento
15 anno vado sul personale è dell'idea
che ho inseguito la filosofia
professionalmente per una quindicina
d'anni e ora è lei che segue me in un
certo senso adesso che mi occupo di
tecnologie questo è la metafora in senso
meno personale cioè l'idea che le
tecnologie
ci diano da pensare ma noi non riusciamo
tanto a stare dietro al loro sviluppo
così rapido e veloce
tra l'altro su twitter che una specie di
paese delle meraviglie parlerò di
meraviglia questo il tema
il titolo non lo non l'ho inserito messo
un immagine ma misteriosa all'inizio
perché poi capirete alla fine
l'abbiamo intitolata appunto condividere
l'incanto
l'idea è che che senso ha la meraviglia
sui social media adesso dicevo twitter è
una specie di paese delle meraviglie
quando riesce ad esserlo e canto non è
l'unica identità che twitta dal passato
sul conto su twitter
c'è chi si è preso la briga di twittare
l'intera seconda guerra mondiale come
fosse un emb ed journalist
dentro gli eventi della seconda guerra
mondiale un progetto di uno studente di
oxford sente di storia che mescola
appunto quello che adesso viene definito
lo storytelling in digitale con la
storiografia quindi la cosa interessante
è che lui twitta esattamente gli eventi
quando capitano è un progetto che dura
sei anni quindi
questo
è una di quelle cose che ti sorprendono
quando vai su un social media come
twitter e tra l'altro non ci sono solo
entità che twittano del passato o dal
passato su twitter ci sono anche entità
che twittano da pianeti lontani questa è
una foto che ha mandato giù cosi ti
rover che un robottino che è stato
lanciato un po di tempo fa e che è
atterrato su marte il 5 di agosto
qualche giorno fa ed è importante che si
chiami incuriositi perché un altro tema
importante è quello dell'esplorazione e
le tecnologie
quello che voglio una tesi quella
difendere dovrebbero aumentare la nostra
capacità di esplorare
da altro esempio di questi giorni la
vetra visto anche su qualche sito
italiano su qualche giornale italiano
questa è stata una scoperta la scoperta
di una nuova specie di insetto questa è
una crisi sapevo che esistesse prima di
vedere questa immagine è successo che
uno studente malese è affatto una gita
nelle foreste vicino a casa il suo ha
fatto questa foto costato la sua foto su
flickr che un grande sito un database
fotografico enorme un entomologo in una
città americana la vede per puro caso
e non aveva mai visto questa specie di
insetto però con quel
dettaglio colorato meraviglioso sulle
ali al che appunto contatta l'autore di
questa foto e si innesca un rapporto per
cui alla fine questo studente riesce a
catturare un esemplare e l'entomologo
alla prova dell'esistenza di un nuovo
smi la nuova specie di insetto queste
sono le cose che possono capitare in
epoca appunto di condivisione
fotografica estesa sul web
e per rimanere in tema zoologico
questa è un'altra foto condivisa
parecchio in questi ultime settimane ed
è appunto un piccolo gorilla che si che
si sorprende della temperatura glaciale
dello stetoscopio posto sul petto dal
veterinario che lo sta visitando
l'espressione è pazzesca mente umana
ovviamente
ed è interessante per due motivi intanto
per il commento che c'è lì sotto perché
dice
pensate che appunto un giorno sarà in
grado di scagliarvi una buick addosso in
wixson quelle grosse macchine americane
ed è stato tra i commenti più votati e
l'altra cosa interessante che in realtà
è l'esemplificazione di uno stupore al
quadrato ci sono due milioni di persone
che si sono stupite del
stupirsi di questo piccolo animale
quello che insomma questa carrellata di
immagini anche un po pop
volevo volevo più sostenere il fatto che
la meraviglia e un po la moneta corrente
delle tecnologie sociali di questi di
questi anni noi ci concentriamo tanto
sull'amicizia perché fare farsi gli
amici su facebook oppure
l'amore per i siti di dating online all
odio però
in realtà ciò che muove tutte queste
tecnologie e la voglia di meravigliarsi
di fatto e ciò che muove a condividere è
ancora sostanzialmente quella che
cartesio un filosofo del seicento
definiva come la prima
tra le passioni
questa è la definizione è ancora
insuperata della meraviglia data da
cartesio e una sorpresa improvvisa
dell'anima che induce appunto l'anima
stessa considerare con attenzione gli
oggetti che le sembrano rari e
straordinari tradizionalmente la
meraviglia e l'innesco punto della
conoscenza
già nel tetto di platone era il
principio della filosofia poi insomma
ripreso anche da aristotele ed è un tema
che continua
cartesio al merito diciamo così di
rendere evidente una cosa che tra le
passioni la meraviglia e quella più
anomala perché tutte le passioni l'amore
l'odio
tutte le altre fanno una cosa
sostanzialmente ci impediscono di
ragionare
mentre la meraviglia
secondo cartesio e serva della ragione
ci serve per conoscere sostanzialmente
una passione fretta perché non implica
particolare i sentimenti anti si mescola
quei sentimenti e una passione visiva è
innescata da ciò che vediamo è una
passione appunto anomala perché si
attiva quando vediamo delle cose che
sono fuori della norma e infine appunto
è l'innesco della conoscenza
cartesio si era occupato parecchio di un
oggetto prototipico della meraviglia un
oggetto un meraviglioso come si direbbe
l'arcobaleno l'arcobaleno è una di
quelle cose appunto tratto nell'epoca di
cartesio
le teorie dell'arcobaleno dei veri best
seller è stato lui a spiegarla
scientificamente di fatto
parlando del fenomeno della rifrazione
poi newton ne ha spiegato anche il
cromatismo sempre in quel giro di anni è
appunto questo è lo schema cartesiano
che implica appunto la posizione di un
osservatore poi rifrazione riflessione
in gocce d'acqua
c'è da chiedersi se la meraviglia
svanisce con la spiegazione
c'è anche da dire che spesso le teorie
il problem solving e invece il
prolungamento della meraviglia estate
haifa i passi di una scoperta
scientifica o di una teoria matematica
resta il fatto che la meraviglia
innescata dall ignoranza dal fatto che
non sappiamo delle cose non le
conosciamo e ci viene voglia di
conoscerlo e ci stupiamo nel conoscerle
la meraviglia di eccessi degli accessi
la ricerca generi a degli accessi
cartesiani era consapevole diceva ad
esempio che la sorpresa può in realtà
renderti insensibile a ciò che di
straordinario ti sta intorno a questa
inquietantemente diciamo
analoga la posizione cioè la distrazione
tra talete di mileto che questo di
questo signore qua e un passante che
controlla il suo il suo telefono mentre
attraverso la strada tra mente di mileto
stava osservando gli astri e narra una
storia cade in un pozzo
il passante ovviamente sta mandando un
messaggio sta guardando appunto facebook
quel rischio è una distrazione che il
fato l'eccesso l'ossessione nei
confronti del nuovo può renderci
insensibili a quello che sta intorno
facciamo il passante col telefono però
un vantaggio rispetto a talete perché
c'è un'applicazione
che consente di mandare messaggi
guardando esattamente dove stai andando
mentre talete ha dovuto far riferimento
soltanto al riso della servetta traccia
la leggenda vuole che ci fosse una
servetta traccia nei paraggi che si mise
a ridere proprio quando cartesio e
piombato nel pozzo questa stava a
ricordargli il fatto che a forza di
guardare in cielo la verità iper urania
stava per stava appunto
dimenticando tutto quello che di buono e
di bello mi stava intorno
quali sono i pericoli diciamo così gli
amici della meraviglia su internet in
generale sui social media in particolare
è un fenomeno vinciamo una tecnologia
quella che si chiama di
personalizzazione ci sono tecnologie che
ci raccomandano libri ci fanno vedere
post
oppure ci restituiscono risultati di
ricerca sulla base delle nostre
preferenze signor base della nostra
interazione con i servizi che ci danno
questi risultati quindi voi
la cosa interessante che se fate una
ricerca su google localizzato a trieste
e palermo
avete probabilmente dei risultati
diversi che sono settati sul nostro
luogo fisico oltre che sulla vostra
storia di ricerca quel pericolo e il
fatto di rimanere inconsapevoli del
fatto che ci sono cose che ignoriamo
quindi non sappiamo che ci sono cose che
non sappiamo esatto contrario
dell'adagio socratico che era appunto
sapere di non sapere quindi la spinta
alla conoscenza questo esatto contrario
perché non
manca l'innesco della curiosità il gap
informativo che ci fa partire e in più
ci offre un ignoto
addomesticato quindi se ci piacciono i
libri gialli amazon ci farà vedere altri
libri gialli non ci farà vedere magari
dei messaggi di storia questo è il
problema è il problema del disincanto
digitale è quella che il fondatore di
moveon e teorico del
bolle dei filtri lai parisi chiama la
bolla dei filtri questo è uno schema
diciamo così giusto per far vedere più o
meno dove si collocano ai più grandi
social media adesso sulla linea che
sull'asse
intrappolamento informazionale
personalizzazione eccessiva e
serendipity ovvero
capacità di offrire casualità negli
incontri con le informazioni ai
contenuti la cosa che è interessante per
me e poi vi spiegherò il perchè è che un
gruppo di servizi basati sulla
fotografia sulla visione diciamo questo
le immagini è tra quelli che offre più
capacità di meravigliarsi e di scoprire
cose nuove
dove c'è il punto interrogativo c'è come
di un'opportunità di design pazzesca chi
si trova quella chi è capace di
implementare attraverso degli algoritmi
la casualità ha trovato diciamo
l'uovo di colombo
c'è qualcuno che ha proposto modello
per riempire quel vuoto diciamo di
design social media e facendosi di nuovo
al passato nella storia e alla filosofia
del passato in particolare riferendosi
alla figura quella del dl flaneur
flanella erano teorizzati da walter
beniamini ma prima la scharbo drexler
che sta a sinistra beniami as titolo di
ha scritto di baudelaire in paio di
saggi poterle prima il flaneur il
botanico del marciapiede l'esploratore
urbano che vagava per la città per oplà
parigi di fine ottocento scoprendo le
novità e in maniera distaccata diciamo
dalla massa cercando appunto la sorpresa
continua dietro gli angoli dei bulgari
il dibattito è attuale sono stati degli
scambi molto interessanti su new york
times e atlantic
a proposito della possibilità di avere
il flaneur come modello di design per i
social media qualcuno ha proposto un
analogia tra ambiente urbano e ambiente
online un fatto che comunque anche
l'ambiente online in fatto di passaggi
successivi e di appunto strade che puoi
percorrere oppure no
e
qualcuno ha anche fatto degli
esperimenti
come sovrapponendo i luoghi fisici e
luoghi virtuali
questo è un progetto di un designer
londinese che si chiama james righton e
si chiama robot planner è una
usa google street view cioè che la
possibilità di vedere su delle mappe
esattamente il luogo in cui sei anzi
luogo che vuoi vedere perché sono
fotografie scattate appunto in loco
scegli la città e poi random ti vengono
proposte immagini di quella città come
se le esplorarsi appunto come forse
baudelaire che cammina nella parigi di
fine ottocento
il flaneur appunto
di questi tempi francia nerd dei social
media diciamo così è un flyer che è
dotato di connessione mobilità è una
cosa che ad esempio susan sontag e
attualmente avrebbe avrebbe aggiunto
nella sua definizione del fotografo come
estensione della figura del flaneur in
questo saggio sulla fotografia del 1973
di fatto il flaneur e non soltanto
fotografo ma è anche connesso e diciamo
qui in questo
nella sovrapposizione di questi cerchi e
di queste di questi trend diciamo
è collocato nella tranne ricordate la
family digitale quindi un aspetto ludico
pensate a servizi come foursquare che ti
consente di essere
delocalizzati in certi luoghi e sfidare
degli altri diciamo a frequentare quei
luoghi
la condivisione fotografica in mobilità
pensate da fenomeni come instagram che
una applicazione al punto di
condivisione fotografica di successo e
la geolocalizzazione del fatto che tu
possa come ogni smartphone ormai è
dotato di gps sanno facciamo degli in
telephone sa dove sei e quindi tutto
questo insieme di informazioni
in realtà quello che produce un effetto
di flannery digitale
tutto questo io voglio metterlo a
sistema siamo in un progetto che quello
che sto per seguendo un progetto in cui
la curiosità la ricerca delle idee nuove
la meraviglia siano il tema centrale e
per questo ho pensato che se dobbiamo
avere una tag line come si chiama un
specie della domanda che trovi ad
esempio nel box i nodi facebook che ti
chiede
appunto ma che cosa stai pensando no
oppure il
tag line di twitter che segui i tuoi
interessi
pensavamo che non se il focus e la
meraviglia ne parlai migliore di questa
non potesse esserci ovvero che cosa hai
scoperto oggi e questo è tutto grazie